how's it going everybody it's Warren and
last night the president of Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige went on reddit and
did a live ask me anything and he
answered a lot of questions some not so
meaningful but some very meaningful like
the fact that Marvel actually has plans
for the Mandarin and the ten rings to
return to the MCU and of course some
people asked about new characters come
into the MCU and Kevin Feige answered
them I'll talk about the questions and
the answers but first if you're new to
my channel be sure to subscribe at the
400,000 subscriber mark I'm doing a
giveaway picking three winners to choose
one Marvel Legends series item for
themselves alright so like I said it
wasn't asking me anything on Reddit and
a few people thought to ask Kevin Feige
if new characters will be coming to the
MCU anytime soon and in his answers each
time he said soon one person asked him
who is someone that's yet to appear in
the MCU that you are itching to
introduce and he responded you'll know
soon enough another person asked who is
your favorite Marvel character that
isn't in the current MCU and he replied
I never play favorites but there are
many Marvel characters that I've loved
for many years that are heading to the
MCU soon but I can't be more specific
than that sorry
so in this answer he said that there are
actually many characters about to enter
the MCU soon now we know there's going
to be an eternal movie a black widow
movie Doctor Strange - but don't forget
about the Disney Plus series Disney Plus
offers a lot of opportunities to see
characters that we have not seen yet in
the MCU and for those of you wondering
yes the Disney Plus series that air are
going to be completely tied into the MCU
in fact this is a question that Kevin
Feige answered on reddit somebody asked
him how much will the Disney Plus shows
weave into the films and he answered
totally and completely and he's already
addressed this before
he's already said whatever happens in
these new series will directly affect
the movies so essentially we're getting
a big expansion of the MCU that offers a
lot of room to introduce new characters
so with the new movies and the new shows
coming out we're going to have a lot
more characters into this bigger MCU and
like I said we already know about some
movies and some shows coming out but
they're probably a lot more coming that
we don't know about and now mark
and Disney have the rights to the x-men
and the Fantastic Four and that's a
whole nother universe to be added into
the MCU to add a ton of new characters
but Kevin Feige did say that he will
talk about the face for slate after
spider-man far from home comes out in
theaters so we're not too far away in
like Kevin Feige said in a few of his
answers everything is going to happen
soon
so last night Kevin Feige the president
of Marvel Studios confirmed that there
are many characters coming to the MCU
soon let me know what you think about
what he said and let me know which
characters you are most excited about to
enter the MCU and again don't forget to
subscribe to enter my giveaway for a
chance to win a Marvel legend series
collection item and of course you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU hit the thumbs up button if
you enjoyed this video and as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]